hé je suis Michael Bay réalisateur de
Transformers Dark of the Moon c'est
enfin ici les éditions ultimes
qui ont quatre disques ici
il y a le blu-ray 3d qui a été
remasterisé c'est ainsi que vous êtes
censé voir ce film aussi  à l'intérieur
ici, il y a la version 2d du blu-ray,
nous avons également ce que je considère comme la
meilleure section bonus que nous ayons jamais faite, c'est
trois heures, un documentaire d'une heure
sur l'équipe de tournage qui nous suit à travers
le monde à chaque tour et tour que nous  a
pris le contrôle de Chicago sur la façon de
faire cette bête d'un film, il a une
excellente section sur la façon dont nous avons réellement
conçu et filmé les Birdmen volant à
travers Chicago, il a sa section sur
les grands artistes sur lesquels j'ai
travaillé du concept à la réalisation il y a
aussi un fabuleux documentaire de la nasa
ici et Optimus n'est pas inclus c'est à
moi
vous